rim donc on est on est en direct sur sur
twitch comme tous les jeudis soirs à
partir de 20 heures
vous voyez que j'étais entre alizé d'une
partie sans temps de faire une vidéo en
fait avant avant de commencer ce stream
est allé en attendant que les gens
arrivent tout ça est de voir si tout
marche bien je vais pas me gêner je vais
mettre la partie de maxime
je vais mettre la partie de maxime
contrat nand comme ça on est tranquille
heures comment ils commençaient
cavaliers h3c 5 c 4 cavaliers f6 look
est donc née anglais symétrique elle est
une balance des 4 ok on va voir on va
voir ce que fait ce que fait notre amie
anne on dit si enfin notre ami dans ce
club ami maxime du taux maximal et noir
et je suis un petit peu je suis un petit
peu à la rue lance début de ce début de
streamserve allemand vient juste de
commencer on va faire des beats no en
direct de voir comment maxime réagi alan
danon qui partagent la première place
d'heures avec maxime s'est il fait un
beau tournoi non une impression qui
choisit un peu ces tournois mais quand
il est en forme il continue de faire mal
l'indien il continue de faire très très
mal
je veux juste me connecter donc
rapidement sur twitter et après on va
pouvoir y aller on va faire un peu d
bliss et puis on suivra peut-être la
partie 2-2 maxime en fil rouge en fait
un tout bêtement on fera un fil rouge et
on va appeler ça
parti en me disant que ça parties en
blitz comme ça on est bien on va ouvrir
le chat comme ça on a le chat sait pas
si on aura beaucoup beaucoup de monde ce
soir on verra bien façon ce sera en pire
au pire en replay sur sur youtube
c'était vous êtes en train de regarder
un replay sur la chaîne youtube de check
point com est donc allé nous on va y
aller j'imagine que ça marche pas tant
qu'à une confirmation du tchad ce sera
cool et on va proposer à l'est des
parties en trois minutes
on a un petit peu beats et et on joue
contre eux élevé du coup trois lettres
peut l'appeler peut-être liev moitié
youssoufou qui nous dit on a du coup il
fait ses 5 ressemble un petit peu à
partie deux dans l'esprit de la partie
de maxime c'est une théorie contre la
trompe offs qui ici ces dames c'est un
droit que nous avons joué tous âges
sismiques ont arrêté mais qu'on va
commencer à faire ça directement
ok pour développer nos pièces
géométriques la f3 ça évitera toujours
qui m qui viennent en russie 5 avec
lecavalier
allez on va venir avec le fou en d3
c'est un petit peu tape espions waroquet
pour le moment je pense pas qu'ils
puissent bouffer le pion aussi ça qui
fait grand roque
ça donne envie de faire tomber un ça me
permet de libérer madame la protection
du pion b2 je vais préparer des quatre
en fait on va faire à troyes b 4 ça va
pas faire de mal devant une colonne
devant le roi adverse 1 jamais une
mauvaise chose
la position de recomposer donc il veut
jouer sur sa colonne ouverte à lui
j'hésite entre mètres la tour en b2 b3
alors en d2 le problème c'est qu'il peut
y avoir des soucis sur cette diagonale
et en b3 le problème c'est que par des
soucis sur celle là
du coup j'ai envie de dire choix
cornélien jeu sont plutôt b3 quand même
parce que peut-être éventuellement je
veux faire dame b 1
du coup la toux protégerait le cavaly
aurait pu ces problèmes de clouage mais
bon il faut il aurait fallu calculer un
pour être sérieux
puis on prend ici
il est obligé de faire cavalier prendre
on perd peut-être du matos directement
ce très possible ok bouge le roi je vais
en profiter pour mettre mon autre tour
en b1 ça ça me rassure maintenant j'ai
peut-être si on prend ces cinq tours
prend bessette qui traîne alors du coup
ok du coup tour c'est cette ok si je
prends il prend de la dame
si je fais p5 c'est complètement débile
ça va tout faire mais si je fais à 4 il
va prendre je vais prendre il va
remettre sa dame ici
je faire à 4 mais je le sens pas trop je
suis ni tuer et était censé faire du
bullet non non tu devais avoir envie de
face du bullet mais je fais absolument
ce que j'ai envie c'est quand même très
très cool du coup on va aller attaquer
le pion de behcet est si faible et si ce
n'est pas peut-être s'il ouvre les cases
blanches
mais sur b6 et peut-être envie de faire
à 5
bloqués dont qui protège à fond assez
logique
j'ai bien envie de faire cavalier de dca
j'ai envie de ramener un cavalier en b5
et de reprendre d'un cavale après emblée
5 pour venir attaquer la tour et quoique
je suis même pas peut-être reprendre
d'un pion j'ai pas trop mais loïc le
quart ayant des quatre îles au centre il
est forcément bien placé ce ne peut pas
être agréable à jouer ça pour les pour
les noirs de façon si fait assises du
fer tourbe et si c'est comme ça je le
ferai tout pour un incident prend des
huit matchs
ok je m'attendais un peu à ce coup
première vue les faits recueillis
prendre les cinq prises puis on prend et
surtout prend des quatre prendre du
plomb je vais aussi faire qui a et b 5
intermédiaires non je vais faire ma
première impression je vais prendre et
prendre il n'y a pas de maths du couloir
attention parce que j'échoue f1 ok seif
4 et là du coup je crois pas que ça
marche mais je le tente
ok il peut pas prendre du kiosque à tour
prend des huit matches mais il peut
prendre du fou prise prisé sur dame
prend le problème c'est que j'aurai pas
fou 4 à cause de dames c'est un math ami
sam série shake down d1 mais je suis pas
sûr que ça m'intéresse de jouer ça du
coup il peut faire dame prend ici il
peut faire dame prend surtout casillas
d'âme des uns qui est très très ennuyeux
mais aucun n'a fait retour prend un f4
du coup on va changer notre fusil
d'épaulé
il ya toujours égalité matérielle sauf
que là la position s'est un peu éclairci
pour nous on as ton premier set quand
même tout cas toujours ce fut f1 qui
sauve tout ok il lévite mais là
maintenant on a une très bonne position
alors je vais peut-être commencer par
faire h4 comme ça j'ai plus à penser aux
maths du couloir et après on réfléchira
à comment progresser
tata 5 à 6 d'ailleurs fait une idée peut
lui force affaire à six mètres la tour b
4 on va revenir c'était dans l'idée
toute façon on va faire à 5 comme si sûr
assis son affaire tourbe et six tours
prend 1,6
tellement et aux menaces peut-être à 6
humana cette tourbe et 6 et surtout on
prend qui on prend et mater sur la
colonne à on a beaucoup de thèmes ici
j'ai envie de le tenter parce que c'est
le beau jeu tomber si c'est vraiment le
beau jeu madame c5 ça tien trung qui est
tombé 5 maintenant on va les taper le
pion des cinq cas je vais faire g3 on va
éviter toutes les histoires de maths du
couloir mais maintenant on va taper le
pion des cinq en force
ok mais là on fait fou et 4 et on va les
taper
on va les mater en force pour le beau
jeu d'argent pour le beau jeu bout le
beau jeu voilà pour le beau jeu à fond
nous sommes toujours pour le beau jeu on
sonne toujours pour le beau jeu tout le
temps quoi qu'il se passe le beau jeu
quoi qu'il se passe
le beau jeu bon mais c'était sympa cette
partie se faire ça vous a plu
toujours pour le beau jeu toujours
toujours toujours quoi qu'il se passe
quoi qu'il se passe le beau jeu c'était
sympa ce qui t'a drague de maths à la
fin avec pas mal de telles tactiques ya
peut-être des choses plus simples mais
bon ah on retombe frottant virement
d'une dans une scandinave c65 jouer les
grandes lignes
gk tâche 4-1 la variante on envoie les
plombs qui avait les 17 cavaliers prend
cavaliers prend et c'est ça la théorie
est fou et 4 après
alors ça je connais pas
qui peut réfléchir du coup j'ai envie de
prendre une fois et de faire cavalier e
4 en fait l'idée c'est que je vais aller
faire qu'il prend ces trois dames france
et 3 encaissés à 1
et s'il fallait donc si fashion comme ça
j'ai le temps de l'échappée avec le
fouet si c'est fou des deux je pense
avoir le temps de faire cavalier prend
dame prend foulée 4g recloux et puis
j'aurai le temps de sortir en dessous en
temps voulu donc aucun à faire ça je te
passe un petit tour des huit au passage
car elle ça mange pas de pain de faire
tourner 800 roms n'a salam une petite
fois on sera en capacité voilà prêt à y
avait des micros de cinq échecs à le
manque de concentration d'un procès cinq
échecs c'était juste écrasant à la la la
j'ai joué trop vite alors ma sphère h5
qu'on menace de prendre et peut-être de
faire flasher 5 houphouet f5 derrière
j'ai pas une arme sur un peu compliqué
quel dommage après cinq échecs c'était
tellement simple
c'est trop simple pour être vrai c'était
beaucoup trop simple pour être vrai j'ai
envie de prendre de la tourment wache
menaces et e5 réussi à tout défendre
pour le moment on va continuer à menacer
tour des quatre partis assez marrante
finalement où les tours arrive arrive en
force en jeu et menacé un peu tout non
mais là c'est un peu tous les genres et
à peut-être fait refouler 3 pour essayer
de l'entité un peu de matos dont il veut
tout défendre réussi pour le moment à
défendre quasiment tous
je n'ai quasiment le scalp ion ces deux
ans prise
mais bon j'ai pas envie de le prendre
j'ai envie de faire tour f 5
je suis pas sûr sur deux tours f5 je
suis pas sûr à 100% je vais retour est 5
fois 5 pour menacer la tour qui protège
la génération qui va être surchargés là
quand même faut quand même pas abuser
laquelle énormément de choses qui sont
attaqués là tous ces pièces sur la
première c'est rarissime comme position
comme au québec a été surchargé tonton
rendent là ok sentais bien que ces
pièces étaient mal placés qu'il était
surchargé à lille a refusé le défi du
coup on va prendre un autre adversaire
cp cana les directives et les
discussions directes
les premiers messages russell lui céder
désactive à 10,6 et ne veut pas une
paille n'y a pas de discussion
allez on va dire que si ce n'est ce
patron peuvent ski plein de variantes
jouable évidemment on va tenter ça alors
ici je joue avec ses cinq plus tôt avec
les blancs en fait du coup je peux enfin
théoriciens
alors à jouer avec gt5 c'est dans
l'esprit je sais pas peut-être on veut
faire un truc comme fou g7 et j'ai
quatre par coups g7 et peut-être faire
j'ai quatre pour aller taper le pion à
eux ok ils empêchent quand j'avais une
pays six mamans
le six fours et sept en tout cas on sait
s'ils sont heureux menaces espion
ce qui est bizarre comme position
affaire à six ont empêché qui a et b 50
le combler cet étrange composition je
pense pas avoir très bien joué c'est
faire b5 damas 5 1 et grand roque bryan
hitch sais pas je comprends pas trop en
fait ce que veut dire ce pion de 5
je préfère c'est une fesse une faiblesse
win for cyril ses affaires g34 ce sera
pénible mais bon peut-être le temps de
faire des simples dames à saintes grand
roque et faire f 6 après dans le bon
tempo
graff rb5 du coup tours j'ai pas trop
compris vont ils peut-être s'enlever de
de clouage éventuel auquel on va faire
la dame en b 6
ok il va il va vers la case aj 5 ça
c'est bien joué de sa part d'ailleurs
j'avais pas vraiment pensé à ça ses
statuts et b4
je faire damas cinq je remette le
calvaire des cinq au québec et h5 ça
c'était prévu a fait retour g8 on va
juste protéger va peut-être faire foi je
suis je sais pas en fait si c'est
vraiment grave s'y prend souvent au
final ce fou n'étaient pas si bons au
caire a joué avec des quatre on va y
aller en force on va peut-être faire
cavalier ses trois échecs
je crois que ça marche pas kessé trois
prises prise
tour des trois fours en f3 bon allez on
tente c'est le beau jeu c'est le beau
jeu qui a été prise ici intermédiaire
ça c'est vraiment embêtant
c'est vraiment embêtant c'est être trop
de beau jeu en fait là
ouhlala ouais là on n'a plus rien passer
n'importe quoi le beau jeu est repoussé
six fours b5
on va essayer mais bon j'y crois pas une
seconde femme c'est qu'on a aucune
menace il peut juste faire dame eux deux
et on me lasse rien en fait
houda me 4 mais ok on tente on tente
tante à fond
on n'a vraiment plus rien quel dommage
sky c3 vraiment mal joué mais je pensais
juste hors france et 3 et abandon 1
je sais pas à quoi ils pensent tâche est
fou c'est 6 du coût qui sait
un truck series s'il ne réussit vraiment
pas ma m'activer outre mesure à faire
[ __ ] en f3 et on va prendre aux 5ème
et apprendre ici intermédiaire alors
vraiment plus actives on va abandonner
abandonnée elle à dire ça a l'air assez
bon il ne veut pas rejouer
bon tant pis ne voulez-vous qu'une
partie
chez notre adversaire
on attend un autre mais en attendant
notre défi en attendant notre défi
alors
sur ce nous donne un nom pas vous dire
de ne pas beaucoup de joueurs titrés
probablement à cause de la think you
feel cap malheureusement hockey des jo
une figurine art qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire de taquin rageux avec g3
je croix rouge et 2 alors voir ce qui
fait alors ce qui fait 5 et on va faire
ses 4 et qu'on va essayer d'attaquer le
centre vu qu'il a mis son cavalier ans
et si ce qui n'est pas forcément très
bien placé ok venir en c2 tout le bien
qu'on lui souhaite
on surfe et calais c3 farc et ses deux
tours c'est un récit ont fait qu a
laissé ses trois fils et je suis pas
faire ou quatre intermédiaires
je comprends et je prends allez on va
faire ça c'est intéressant
si j'arrive à faire ça et e4 en fait il
est si fekkai prochain je vais prendre
un f5 ok mais si fait ça quel jeu prend
avec lecavalier
ok tu prends ici
mais que je vais prendre une fois sur
échec je vais faire un échec
je vais faire le beau jeu je prends mon
des 5
je sais pas ce que ça donne c'est être
absolument idiot ce que je viens de
faire
est ce que j'étais en train de me dire
b5
ça a l'air assez fort puisque sur ces 7
puis on prend fou c6 est en fait il ya
rien du coup je me retrouve à prendre ce
truc là
simplement
alors attendez il faut quand même
réfléchir il ya son truc là qui est
bloqué bates est vraiment pas le coup
que j'aurais joué j'ai vraiment fait
dams et 7 mais bon j'ai envie de rester
là
ok mais ce truc à faire cette dame b 4
me cacher ma joie est madame en e2 du
coup phasage protège b2g dame b 4 quand
même je ne comprends absolument rien à
cette partie je vais peut-être d'un
prince arrive je comprends rien fait
qu'elle ait faire c'est cette gt tour
c'est 8 chf est fou c'est six échecs qui
fait recette je fais ou g5 et d'un prend
b2 ok mais là je prends ça
je ne comprends absolument rien à ce qui
se passe acer joue très vite et très mal
je pense
mais je vous c'est un peu déstabilisant
sq real sont rois et quand même
complètement à la rue
ces pièces sont hyper mal placé il ya
aucune harmonie dans ce qui fait qu'il
donne une dame d'un coup maintenant le
mec est juste très étrange
franchement nul admettons je ne comprend
aucun coût de nos adversaires vraiment
qui je veux juste faire de la médecine
dame ici que vous pouvez prendre ça
qu'elle est juste pas très bien je veux
non plus mais c'est juste que je suis
très déstabilisés par ces coups en fait
dans toute la partie j'étais très
déstabilisée par sa carrière de jouets
bon maintenant je suis en 4 sur échec et
ça va débarrasser avec le pion g qui
file le mec jeu jusqu'au bout
elle se fait tour je sais ce que je vais
faire demain ça tient c'est complètement
débile j'aime bien je serai obligé de
donner la dame tient il répond par un
truc encore plus débile
allez tiens hop c'est du jamais eu en
fait
bon j'ai pas j'suis pas quoi penser de
ce jour je pas envie de rejouer contre
lui puisque la partie était trop bizarre
et pas intéressante c'est pas vraiment
un confiance redis je ne comprend aucun
coup de mon adversaire c'est toi qui
joue très très bien
soit ils jouent très très mal
généralement et la lui c'est juste
hallucinant fait j'en crois qu'en il a
super musclé ce camp comme je dirai
combien sont partis c'est absolument
sublime tout ce qu'il a fait enfin j'en
rajoute peut-être un petit peu mais
enfin il a juste très mal joué salut
c'est cha cha cha cha mais elle a été
étonnamment mauvais étonnamment mauvais
on a réussi pas jouer un joueur entré en
jeu apple compte et punk oms à la base
il prend un pion dégage du masque
m'attendent leur passage qu'on peut être
soit très bon réalité comme base pour
les noirs ça en partie longue mais qui
en oublient de c'est bien ça permet de
donner un pion lors beaucoup beaucoup
d'activités évidemment cette grand roque
je passe sur skoda me 7 tev vraiment bon
on peu de la merde
j'aime pas trop comment comment j'ai
joué ici ok je pense qu'il joue avec
grand roque
vous jetez pas jennifer roi v8 pour
commencer je me sera toujours utile je
suis les conseils de bentzmann gold
d'autre part les trucs juste entre la f6
g5 doit me prendre à mach 4
donc je prends ici quand même très ok je
vais faire je vais 5g furent peur de ce
qui arrive en d5 en fait et je vais
faire dame le 5 mai je lisais se purger
5 me permet d'éviter fouet 4 qui se fait
recaler des cas ça permet d'éviter tour
f5
je vais faire h4 après ce coup je pense
qu'il faut aller vers tous rêvent 2 pour
sûr h4 avoir g4 j'imagine un j'imagine
je n'en sais rien ce sont les
suppositions
qui est sûre ashkan du coup
je convaincs trop ce qui va ce qu'en
fait prendre ce pion sert à rien ça me
permet de faire cavalier h6 sur tempo au
calme au cas où
et là je les scanne sont plongés trois
genres s'y fait ces trois je peux
peut-être même juste ignorée en fait et
après j'aurais fait plus on prend je
fais tout reproche 2,3 à g1 dame prend
h43 f1 et d'atouts rachat je vais gagner
la dame
du coup il peut pas vraiment faire ces
trois mon avis mais du coup puis on
prend option franche des trois c'est une
très forte menace je comprends vraiment
pas ce qu'il a fait j'aurais vraiment
fait je juge je reviens à lui je reviens
pour la partie lâche on nous aurait fait
à main tu peux pas ah oui c'est ma
partie donc je ne peux pas mais j'aurai
fait tout rêve de et g4 ici avec la tour
en f2 pour protéger et là je sais pas du
tout ce qui va faire aucune idée de
comment défense avec les avec les blancs
là deux pions de plus peut-être
cavaliers f4 et le meilleur coût en fait
mais ok dans les pures projet trois ans
fait déjà
je ne sais pas je ne sais pas quelle il
faut déjà jouer un truc pour faire h3
après chercher paroisse g2 puis on prend
et h3 donc il faut être 4 mai au caire
au f4 pas prendre puisque champniers si
on range étroit prise tout reprend voilà
y'a plus rien du coup on est obligé de
prendre et peut-être pions prend
maintenant du coup en moquez cette
touriste que je peux pas l'enfermer 6
juin la dame on réussisse il se barre en
angers7
je ne sais pas pourquoi mon intuition
demi de latran 1,8 plus loin de l'action
et de faire ces six comme ça j'ai une
débarrasser du cavale et je lui tape et
le plus efficace ça m'évitera de jouer
contre un gros centre sera toujours ça
de pris face on n'y a rien sur la 7e il
n'a pas le temps d'organiser une menace
de maths ou quoi que ce soit j'aurai
toujours cavalier e set au pire voilà
comme ça j'ai encaisse là et je vais
revenir dominant
pour admettons mais ce qui menace ces
menaces rien de toute façon en un clic
et f6 au pire on fera court 17 en temps
voulu caffet retour g8 va se débarrasser
de cette tour sur la 7e avant qu'elles
deviennent dangereuses et on va
débarrasser un peu l'échiquier et là on
lui met beaucoup car le cas des cages sa
cause de chips cette charge fait le
chaman alors attends attends une minute
enfin il protège son cas il s'écarte en
plus tu vas prendre ça là bas
ah non il prend sur échec alors quel
idiot fini il s'est juste perdant mon
truc je suis juste déconcentrer comment
est ce que j'ai pu perdre ça c'est un
mystère rôle alors catastrophique parce
qu'on appelle le syndrome bbf ce qui
t'as plus envie de jouer des positions
gagnantes hué perds tu te dis c'est fini
et mais qui s'accroche à fond et il te
bat qu'elle va prendre ça là on va
prendre ça c'est pas tout à fait fini et
j'ai plus de temps
on va essayer de les mater
mais qui n'avait pas l'air hyper doué en
face mais c'est sûr qu'elle ait fait un
truc comme ça
désespérant de personnes lors de parties
désespérant de perdre ce genre de partie
contre ce genre de joueurs n'importe
quoi n'importe quoi non mais ok ok mais
on a encore à faire je ne sais pas mais
c'est c'est le bal des débits
d'aujourd'hui non mais ok mais bon enfin
après avoir si mal joué je veux un truc
complètement perdre en voulant des
plombs le mec fait effet fait ce truc
complètement débile et c'est difficile
juste avoir envie de se concentrer la
norme est juste envie de jouer contre
des gens normaux en fait
pour lui ce n'est pas si mal mais enfin
c'est juste que ça me ça me laisse
perplexe
j'ai assez mal joué en plus du coup
donc je vais tenter un truc de beau jeu
se fait recaler des cinq ans c'est pour
faire du beau jeu poussif et dame prend
des dons faits caillasser 7 et chacun
sur wade 8 sakai prend 2,6 ok il le voit
faire cavalier 3 ha non il ya fou ici
quelle horreur j'avais envie de jouer
cette partie en la commençant déjà
et c'est juste perdre en direct selon
laquelle catastrophe
je te dante si ce qui sauve encore
quelle chance
je prendre ça
ce qui est sûr c'est que je vois rien du
tout là
je perds ce pion laroquais c'est une
horreur vraiment très très mal jouer
cette partie bourthes europe énervé par
la partie précédente assez bien en fait
bizarrement il joue assez vite et assez
bien je dois dire j'ai trouvé du contre
jeu comme on peut
la foire prend ici une fois pour une
deuxième fois
troisième fois cette jouer ce truc là tu
fous de couleur opposée après fou prend
tout reprend hockey à il prend ses deux
enfin deux variantes très bien vu un
look est là pour la peine il a beaucoup
mieux joué que moi enfin il a vraiment
très bien joué en fait nous qu'elle a
vraiment très bien joué cette partie
autant la première l'a très mal joué
autant cela parquet joue un peu tout cas
n'en est peut-être qu'il est beaucoup
trop fort peut-être que efforts qu'on
change adversaires
alors que le mec est beaucoup trop fort
alors
tu sais pas trop ce qui fait
ok
à
qu'est ce que je suis en train de [ __ ]
j'entre à deux super mal joué quoique
h56 n'importe quoi ok j'ai changé
d'adversaire au prochain coup je ne vais
pas d'avancée 8e sera mieux placé
[Musique]
tour en 8e protéger mon pions j'ai fait
pas mal de débilité en début de partie
que peut faire b6 comme ça on aura le
temps de bouger ce cavalier
éventuellement qu'est-ce qui fait qu'est
ce que c'est que ce cavalier en a quatre
je comprends absolument rien
déjà maître madame vert dès cette
semaine la tour ans et 8 du coût pour
défendre le plongeon pas trop ce qui se
passe une nouvelle fois
qu'est ce tu es sûr qu'il allait faire
ça
et allez boom le beau jeu je pense c'est
idiot mais bon moi c'est marrant sur
jusqu'à voyage de il ya absolument rien
mais au caire marc giraud est de faire
de saimone williams 30 vidéos à la sai
manoqué on va faire
mais pas grand chose
je vais prendre un pion je sais pas si
on commence à compter les pions à la fin
de la partie se rassurent pas mal en
avoir un de plus toujours être utile à
revenir ici 60 on n'a pas trop d'
attaques rapides donc un pion sur un
pion
chais pas trop pas grand chose n'a pas
vraiment d'attac
aucune idée quoi faire en fait je n'ai
plus de temps
à
j'arrive pas du tout à prévoir ses coûts
en fait en plus faut toujours un peu
plus vite en fait faut que j'essaye
d'arrêter de jouer de d'arrêter
d'essayer de jouer propre et juste faire
un peu n'importe quoi et on est obligé
de faire une remontée à la puisque après
cette première défaite dans cette partie
vraiment stupide c'est de jouer vite
je parlais des découvertes et des trucs
mais ça c'est bien joué
poussez le pion à fond a menacé maths en
un savoureux ce que ça vaut quelque
chose fait juste faire flouer fin en
fait vraiment que je joue plus vite à
parler prochaine
si je comprends pas pourquoi il a pris
ça
pas
à
waouh je savais absolument rien vu
du coup je mens comme la tour en d1
besançon afin de crier comme des fous
après leur chien on va prendre ça là il
va de nouveau me faire tomber à la fête
la smat en a
ce sera bien battu
à
oh
ah j'avais là nul je sauve l annuler
jaillissant a et le syndrome nimby ouais
ça peut arriver sur internet sur tout
ça arrive sur internet petite
déconcentration et là encore quand c'est
juste qu'ils jouent des contrées bizarre
en fait les adversaires et celui-là en
suisse nous a fait tomber deux fois en
fait servir de objectivement deux fois
il a gagné répondu en fait je veux juste
qu'on joue un peu plus vite je pense et
je découvre vraiment étrange étrange
étrange que je n'arrive pas trop à ok
mais le mec en plus se déconnecte voit
enfin le mec a aucun respect pour rien
horrible malgré ce moi qui fais des
parties de perez mais là quand même
simple différend se déconnecte ne veut
pas faire de riz match avec se
déconnecte
ok
pas le top alors camarades d'el ayoun
c'est vraiment dommage qu'on puisse pas
jouer deux joueurs titrés somme des
parties plus sympa généralement mais ok
c'est la vie donc est normalement tous
et le pion aux 5 si tôt dans la partie
c'est pas une bonne chose
parce que du coup ça va devenir
normalement une faiblesse c'est du coup
on va attaquer le cavalier ci prend va
reprendre du pillon baie et s'y
déplacent le cavalier on va ramener nos
cavaliers enjeux d'un v6 pas très précis
mais bon quand m le kenyan ces sept on
va revenir vers eux 6
donc il veut attaquer comme un malade de
l'autre côté qu'est ce qu'ils font
d'achat si ça va faire fou ici chars
damas 5 et le mec va m'envoyer les pions
c'est sûr il va faire h5 je vais prendre
le pion mais il s'en fiche complètement
c'était évident que je vais prendre deux
f laisse pas si clair comme position je
vais prendre de la dame
j'ai quand même le fouquet au verger qui
avait réussi ce qui est bien placé il
contrôler ces cases la importante fois
çi cependant pas trop possible ce que
prises et enfin ok la g dames 3e 2 mais
dans l'esprit prisé d'am dam crantée
d'alger cinq échecs dans fait
tiens ça c'est bien jouer autour des 5
j'ai fait cavalier f4 en fait surtout
preuve en est un qui prend eu deux
échecs et surtout prend ça va me
permettre de soulager
ok je fais au pire je peux même faire un
nom d'un produit et qui éprouvent de
attention mais je faire dame prenait 4
juste et j'échange quand même sont fous
de cases noires et du coup je fais même
très très heureux avec mon fou dans le
champ kétou je veux éventuellement juste
d ici ça près mais ok j'aurai le fou du
fian qui est toujours et où normalement
ça va je fais des six je libère la
diagonale du fou haye adam procède basse
pas si grave mais bon ça devient pénible
j'arrive pas aujourd'hui bas ils
abandonnent fantastique cic libye tease
et il sait libye teese est bloquée sur
le terrain de cliquer ici c'est
évidemment va pas protéger le pion la
juge ou un truc normal au qui prend le
pion quand tu fais une scandinaves ou
une scandinave est un jeu et détroit du
coup le sent le mec taquin qui va jouer
grand roque du phare rue avec des trois
plus solide ça j'ai une petite petite
idée sur les diagonales j'ai pas de
problème sur ce pion des quatre
peut-être faire j'ai quatre au prochain
dans l'esprit pionnier que le mec vous
conduit par k -o 5 au prochain et je
viens vite maintenant confiants quito
vraiment g4 quand même comme ça je le
prends un peu d espace gym est madame
ans je vais te fous en g2 adam en f3
puis je faire fou des deux vallées ont
répondu on va attendre au kg 5 4 avec le
cavalier là je vais faire ces trois des
quatre
ok on va attendre ces pages vous pas
très bien pour le moment mais je suis
pas trop développées en fait du combat
du problème c'est que j'arrive pas à
faire cailler prend des 5es et c3 et
grand roque en fait sur dame de ya
toujours cavalier des 4
bon ok c'est pas top pour le moment
c'est un peu la merde en fait j'ai tenté
ça et je vais faire c'est 3 je vais
retour échec images le roi en f1 c'est
très moche mais dans l esprit de la
grolle d'après j'ai peut-être faire des
4 et puis je vais essayer de les changer
des pièces qui rentrait dans la finale
bref un ce que je t'ai envie de faire
dame h5 d'un proche car être tu vas leur
en f1 enfin pas si mal faut vite le dire
mais c'est pas aussi grave que ça puisse
paraître peut-être encore que qui a aidé
5 très pénible ce qui aura d'amd 5 après
ok mais je fais des cats avec tempo du
coup je suis très heureux parce que
c'est mon idée
je sais pas si j'aurai d'amour h5 ce qui
est ultra présomptueux quand même pour
aller prendre le pion là bas
si juteux d'ahmed strauss kahn je te
faire dame f3 on va peut-être pas se
sentir volets des ailes
ce terrain est chauffé à 5,7 faire d'arc
détroit qui protège qui arrête la tour e
ce ne peut pas être mauvais ça de façon
d'échanger une paire de tours qui ont à
prendre les 8
il va devoir prendre de la dame va faire
dame f4 d'apprendre la dame sait sinon
il est depuis en d5 en prison elle
essaie d'aller choper h4 quand même ce
que pion de plus comme ça puisse choquer
hk tu peux envoyer le pion à h après
boom est comme ça après ma tour
s'activent
bon je prends pas où il veut en venir
avec lecavalier
lorsque je reviens là ok mais s'il veut
venir jusqu'ici c'est pas grave sans
qu'ils aient dit si je suis fou prend
des singes en tapant deuxième vision je
veux faire h saint calais beaumont en
tape un deuxième marocaine est faux pas
va pas pas lu sinequa les poncer des
champions c'est un pion au four 3 bien
s'installant le trou avec le fou comme
ça on défend bien on va mettre la dame
angers 4 leroy eux deux le pion h5 boom
marche avant équipe de france de rugby
quoi troisième ligne on y va et on
envoie les pions de partout d'amener on
protège le cas je m'en fiche complète
avant j'en vois les pions boulin alors
est ce qui fait d'un b5 je refais dame
eux deux en fait
voici jeu complètement lâchement je fais
damage 7
moi qui avais sur dame échec je viens à
angers 200 clients parfois envies
d'étranger 2 mais bon c'est pas grave le
temps qu'ils rasent les pions de l'autre
côté je vais je vais je vais pousser
comme un fou bah je fais j'ai six tours
h5 je rentre type ferdane des cinq
éventuellement mais c'est pas un
problème fait retour h4 je passe sur le
faire dame prend 1,4 ou si on veut faire
tour g4g 6 enfin je sais pas ce qu'on
veut jouer chanson quand même prendre le
pion
à faire bloc 4 el hadjel pas
un truc il faut mettre la marche avant
sans se faire contre attaque et c'est
jamais facile en blitz avait peut-être
tout rachat du kwh à moins que je me
trompe il s'enfermer la dame tout seul
mais on avait réussi un peu à voilà mais
quand même réussi à le faire du spider
man d'espèces de toiles de toiles
d'araignées on va lui laisser refaire
son truc avec le 4 5 1 six il y tient
non ça c'est mauvais coup c'est aux uns
comme ça franchement je ne vous
conseille pas là on va le faire b6 du
coup ça on veut on veut faire un peu
comme on veut faire un espèce de benko
amélioré à mais qui échangent les la
caisse assez malin malin de sa part
comment prendre du coup du coup on a
égalisé matériellement et on n'obtient
pas autant que ce qu'on aurait voulu
concrètement mais quand même pas mal
parce que le pion aux 5 c'est une petite
cible et ont réussi à bouger nos pièces
bon j'ai pas vu ce coup d'amd 5 très
bien vu de sa part d'échanger les dames
sinon c'était dur aucun avec les
cavaliers ans le 6 quand j'imagine petit
truc un peu pénible
j'ai envie de faire tourner les huit
pour attendre m quoique je me mets dans
le jeu mais dans le rayon du fou pas sûr
que ce soit bon donc j'ai envie d'un
petit peut pêcher en eaux troubles pour
le moment parce que j'ai envie de lui
faire céder 600 fait est d'aller le
fonds va on va pêcher en eaux troubles
à
pour le moment c'est pas mal ce qu'on
fait
senna peut attaquer ce qu'on peut
c'est faire x 4 cavaliers ses 4 x 6
échecs on a pas mal de choses à qui
s'approche de son roi quand même c'est
assez menaçants
ça commence à être assez menaçants un
gars on s'écarte pas encore venir la
petit à petit problème là on va faire
flasher 6
ok mais calmes en enfer f4 je sais pas
c'est un adversaire très très étrange et
qu'il y aurait pu faire f4 ici encore et
jouer enfin je sais pas du tout ce que
je vous dis quand on joue contre des
mecs mon titre et je compte la voilà des
monarques se mettre vite français déjà
rarement maître fide ok ça va être plus
ça allait plus sérieuses est plus
sérieux le cas pour mc qui s'est
déconnecté tu peux t'en as pas réussir à
jouer contre lui non plus le rapport a
pas réussi à jouer un jour titre et on
joue en quinze jours un kazakh arman
stan 23 on va voir ce que ça va jouer
avec ses 6 ha ok cet hymne avec vous
aussi ce pour éviter que ces quatre pour
aller tout de suite prendre avec lequel
on 17 quai du coup on voit tout de suite
prendre comme ça on insolite a fait
tomber quatre fois menacé ça mange pas
de pain ok on va la jouer dans l'esprit
on va jouer avec g5 beaucoup plus dans
l'esprit que que le rsa les boums aller
voir ma joue dans l'esprit à fond
au café recul le fou c'est pas grave sur
hk je suis en fait cavalier quatre ans
tout bêtement kf4 il vocifère h 4 10 et
je faire h4 déjà on va voir il va faire
flouer f2 j'ai quand même bien envie de
le faire j'ai quatre en or à cannes pas
mal à avancer les pions et apprécié
jalons pour en sacrifier un pour ouvrir
mais a du coup on a fait une grosse
poussée
ok il veut récupérer la case f4 pour son
cavalier ça c'est plutôt bien joué mais
ok je crois qu'ils feraient que l'époque
où ronde de la folie qu'on va faire p
500 a laissé le roi hausse on doit se
mettre en faillite comme tout à l'heure
et du coup le cas il va rentrer en jeu 5
et va s'envoyer à fond
ça se complique de plus en plus sur gran
qui va peut-être prendre à vii mais
est-ce que c'est grave non je pense pas
j'en profitais pour ok long du coup ci
prend et recettes tant pis on perd un
temps c'est pas si grave à cacher le roi
du coup on va revenir dans un deuxième
temps l'attaqué
ok c'est le bordel
je met le front des six préparer
l'attaquant h2 éventuellement
c'est dur
qui aura poussé ici valeant balancer le
cavalier angers 4 on en a besoin je suis
fou prend à faire cavalier e 4
incertitudes maximum il ya des pièces de
partout qui a eu lieu quatre par mal
placée ce qu'elles font en g3 dans le
viseur
il n'y a pas trop de cas ci prend au
sein qu'on va tout échanger massivement
son roi va se retrouver sans que ces
cases noires sont pas top
surtout que si les changes massives ont
eu cinq ans reprendra de la dame ça
perdra ça permettra pardon à la dame de
revenir en jeu ça c'est plutôt pas mal
qui et 59 secondes c'est pas l'amérique
mais il ya pas mal de ventes qui me
plaisent ok là je pensais prolonger
trois ans va le faire vite
pourtant duel vita sont la partie
j'ai pensé par cavalier prend en fait
nous permet de multiplier les pièces en
attaque le fou non fiasson de porter moi
la garde et peut-être prendre un
référent et vii et prend manger 3 6044
va peut-être faire qui prend f7
je crois 4q les malheureusement
faire un échec rappelons que je manque
un peu de puissance de frappe pour finir
ok ça je suis plutôt content qu'elle ait
envie de tenter ça complètement dingue à
ya juste faire damage 5 ha ça va pas
suffire
quelle menace maths en a une nouvelle
fois et surtout rejet 1
je voulais faire flouer 5 mais du coup
je peux pas ces cinq pas bien joué
du conte très mal joué ok c'était une
partie très sympa mais voilà c'est le
jour du parti qu'on voulait jouer depuis
tout à l'heure du conte en a une je vais
chercher le père pète à je vais me
matter ya houba et xero 0,4 sur la
pendule bout tu dégage tu dégages
laristan 23 ça fait assez plaisir contre
le sorti de nulle part
bref c'est vraiment pas mal joué j'ai
pas j'ai senti que vous aller mater du
coup j'ai senti que vous allez allez
dame et son option les du coup j'ai
senti le matin arrivé quand on a chassé
en nous trouverons un rejoue le maître
fide bon on va faire des quatre à l'est
mais a été sympa la dernière cette
famille propre mais en fait ça je pense
que l'idée dans l'idée j'étais bien à un
moment donné et puis ça va pas marcher
ce truc que je voulais faire assez joli
lectoure h1n1 vont pas toujours faire
les choses qu'on veut un don qu'elle va
faire qu'il y ait des deux régions un
truc tranquille on s'est complètement
raté mon ouverture comme ça c'est fait
alors
complètement raté notre ouverture
vraiment de la merde mais ok à faire
accroire
je chasse et se fout parce qu'en fait si
prend du coup face est horrible aussi un
rêve
tout est tellement horrible en trois
actions d'ouverture plus puisqu'il faut
jouer donc on va laisser échangés je
sais pas du coup on a une juste une
mauvaise position
je pense que la logique veut qu'on aille
attaqué le roi face le beau jeu
un choix
logique de compass du gauche alors
dévaler vers des 5 c'est hyper pénible
mais complètement fou tu es là
vraiment de la merde un sport en train
de faire car tour c1
l'opposition le maire de lille son maire
d'un que je voulais qu'on y fasse l
objet d un peu poussé notre pions
mais comment savoir chasser en eaux
troubles faire tourner ses 3
lecavalier a eu cinq et on va les
sacrifiés comme des malades trois cas la
haye je menace tu mens tu reprends ici
si on prend un tour et touré tour j'ai
trois échecs bon pêche en eaux troubles
j'adore cette expression une expression
il est sorti d'un libre échange c'est
une expression est très très utilisée
aux échecs
je ne pense pas que ce soit mon
expression ok ça empêche notre pêche en
eaux troubles
non mais j'ai envie de dire je fâche
france et jamais qui veulent jouer à
quatre par un travail et vie télé mag du
couloir un moment donné et ça m'a permis
de continuer notre pêche georges ni
peut-être il n'a pas vu que sept cas à 5
ans marque soit un peu naïf de penser ça
mais bon on est là pour s'amuser on y
songe à faire dame siens et tf6 ça du
coup c'est bien fait pour moi j'avais
juste pas du tout miss cookie est très
bien joué c'est bien fait pour moi
il fallait faire l'âme c1 comme je
voulais le faire du bruit fait rage 3
pour tenter mon piège je suis un peu
obligé 30 comme ça va se faire essayer
de faire dame 4 pour compte à une petite
comptine une attaque qui n'existe pas
nogué on est toujours là f5 plutôt bien
joué encore ok bien vu la part de nos
adversaires on a vraiment très mal joué
a réussi à non pourquoi je fais ça moi
je vois un truc que je connais pas là
c'est encore plus débile c'est encore
fui les villes avaient une est indienne
quand on ne joue pas c'est pas du tout
le truc recommandé mercure et essayez
donc apparu que je ne connais pas du
tout
et je soupçonne qu'il faille prendre les
jouets sait si ce que je soupçonne
des cheveux p5 je fais pas la théorie
est donc difficile de vous dire si ce
que je fais est bon ou pas
ces jetons soit mauvaise ce qui répond à
tempo merkel alliée c'est que surprise
prise fou prend tour échec aux essais
iprp lips juste aucune idée de comment
réagit à sa banque et cher h 6
j'ai commencé par oi je sais pas si je
vais prendre maintenant
mais du coup moins sûr fou prend l'idée
c'est que si j'aurais fou prend il y
aura plus de courses et me duré le temps
de faire cavalier à six pour des clous
et on va voir ce que ça donne
les fils de jours un truc qu'on connaît
pas du tout il y avait du coup je perds
crise
ben c'est pas mal si on réussit
davantage à une estonienne qu'on connaît
pas du tout c'est plutôt sympa ça et que
je faire québec à traiter car il y prend
des 5 et j'aurai un film plus ok mais là
dessus je suis arrivé 4 quand même qu'il
prend des cinq voix mature qui viendront
des huit au cas où
donc elles purent an d ici c'est
pourquoi pas mais là dessus je comptais
faire 4
plus j'arrive plus à calculer mais mes
jeunes amis du jeu mais ton qu'ayant des
trois en fait et encaissé le pion des
six en force
ça commençait pas raciste comme ça on
palpe ion b on va faire f 5 comme ça on
donne pas le pion f mais qui ne veut
rien donner cole mais qui perdra dans
shark prend des cathos qui d'ailleurs
avait encaissé cela quand même au
passage un look et je suis assez radin
là dans cette partie mais après je
remette lui qu'alliance c4 comme si
j'avais manqué c'est encore ça mais je
ne veux pas laisser de points en fait
elles vont refaire calice et quatre dans
l affaire tout reprend des six
maintenant qu'est-ce pas mal d'être
radin ça permet de gratter deux pions et
ok on va juste mettre la tour en des 8
à prendre une fois la deuxième fois à
prendre une troisième fois et en mettre
le feu lancés ici ça
ah mince j'ai plus beaucoup de temps au
cadran avec la paire de fou ça va gagner
tranquille qui fuit 3g cette f 5 c'est
mon idée du coup je veux couper le
cavalier des cases noires et puis je
veux commencer à pousser mes pions comme
un malade est repoussée l'épisode agf ou
prendre quatre reprises en un coup d'une
pièce oh la la la la la la
bernanke et c'est ridicule c'est
ridicule de rater un truc comme ça
flambe et quatre ans ferme et le
cavalier en fait faire un demi cercle
sur le cavaliere j'espère que vous
connaissez ce truc d'ailleurs vous allez
le revoir dans la prochaine vidéo que
j'ai fait est donc là le cavalier de
l'ars complètement fermée et du coup on
va en profiter pour échanger les pièces
voilà on va le choquer et voilà les
bonnes techniques pas mal de demi-cercle
et cavaliers a du coup on va faire aux
quatre vents changent et comme on joue
un peu tout à une écossaise bon c'est
bon comme tu peux le la cette variante
de bages préfèrerais jouer cas ici trois
nos quais comme j'ai vu que gilles
d'heure à jouer ça hier contre magnus ça
donne envie de faire comme peter
je me demande cf 4 c'était prématuré ou
pas je ne sais pas ce qu'on prend des
six en échange tout je ne sais pas je
n'ai plus la théorie c'est horrible
c'est vraiment très théorique en fait
cette maison
mais à 81 dame de trois peut-être très
mauvais remède mais peut-être est
peut-être juste puis on prend en fait là
dessus c'est pas ça me paraît faux d'un
me 3 je suis sûr j'ai jamais vue d'un
métro en une variante j'ai l'impression
mais bon je ne sais pas j'ai peut-être
mélange aider à rentrer là dedans ça
joue pas ce qui s'y fait des essais je
veux juste faire flouer de en fait et
c'est une structure que je connais un
petit peu
nicolas tueur est une idée de faire ces
cinq validé cette et cavalier e 2 pour
allait revenir vers des quatre en fait
je touche du singe
essaie de s'accrocher à tout b4
est ce que vous les jours un truc
complètement dans l'esprit
j'ai envie de faire un truc bizarre bon
allez j'ai envie de jouer dans l'esprit
on est là pour se marrer c'est un stream
c'est une vidéo youtube c'est pas c'est
pas la coupe du monde d'échecs jarry sur
calais fuite en fait de faire f5 de
donner deux pions dans salle et qui
avait un f4 bout comme si jean ferme le
foot où ça va j'ai envie de m'amuser
j'ai envie de me faire plaisir on est là
pour s'amuser non j'ai envie de jouer ça
ça me paraissait assez drôle maintenant
dans l'esprit pur est bloquée bloquer
les pièces noires
du même pas du pion me le rend il doit
saisir c'est trop dans l'esprit mais je
pensais bien joué en plus
minc et du coup on a peut-être mettre la
dame chez pas mon verre m dames
voilà maintenant deux peut-être terminée
faire quel point f5 et prendront g7 et
de mettre le fou en b2 en fait hélas
d'amoureux de fuites savamment g7 et hop
du coup obligé de faire des 4l a hobo
grand roque à fond dans l'esprit
toujours dans l'esprit tout le temps
kevin à l'esprit c'était de faire un nom
mince masse mince affaire grand roque
pour commencer sur lequel il prend du
coin fr dame de 5 sur fou prend on verra
sur foot quand j'ai bien envie de jouer
ça cavaliers j'ai ici c'est d'aller le
choper le pion là-bas tour c'est 8 à
d'échoppés là bas j'ai bien envie
d'aller choper le pion à 7 on peut re à
des pions passé dans la finale plus tard
comme ça je vais pouvoir faire fou à 6
pour développer et tour voici fait d'un
f16 comme ça je prends ok mais là c'est
plutôt bien joué
j'espère fois ci c'est quand même du
coup je vais le laisser s'échapper avec
la tour pour garder mon fou monstrueux
mais c'est dommage que ça se joue autant
en fait partie c'est une partie très
agréable à jouer on adversaire très
agréable je ne sais pas qui c'est mais
l'adversaire est agréable et partis sont
sympas je suis passé du grand niveau
mais ça donne des parties sympa à jouer
j'imagine sympa à regarder aussi mais
malheureusement là on est un peu à court
de temps tous les deux donc on va pas
pouvoir continuer notre chef-d'oeuvre
non c'est moi qui ai un peu moins de
temps mais après c'est le sport je ne
prends pas ça tours non je ne te
prendrais pas ta tour
hay al fou qui tombe
je n'avais pas qui est éthique et
certains adversaires mais partir
agréable partie très sympa contre des
mots nax partie très sympa contre ce
petit damon axway
moi je passe icônes et le stream quoi
messi connaît les vidéos maintenant
merci c'était des cités partie très
agréable à jouer
du coup je passe que ça allie son petit
aussi seif 5 mai mais bon c'était une
partie très très cool très très cool
vraiment la partie du stream entre les
trois parties puisque du coup j'avais
envie de mettre en partie du site celle
que j'ai gagné la particularité pas mal
aussi mais ça l'a vraiment très sympa
tactique et ou du coup c'était un
plaisir c'était un plaisir de jeu qu'on
trouve bouchardés malaxe hadji aime
jouer ma bête noire mais j'espère que
vous allez kiffer c'est parti je sais
pas ce que vous avez pensé mais je faire
ça vous a plu
du coup je suis la bête blanche de de
james jolie que tu soit déconnecté très
envie de gagner par des connexions au
troisième jeu je vais très très heureux
c'est un rêve qui pourrait se réaliser
que j'avais des cieux ce 5 est logique
comme j'ai le fou de cases blanches qui
veut bloquer mais ok j'ai ma petite idée
moi je veux la caf cat et je vais te
défoncer au centre oui j'ai plus
d'options que toi j'en ai trois ils sont
la norme une partie sympa contre
debrecen est vraiment plus en fait très
heureux de cette partie je shoote en
super heureux
ok je ne vais touche à rien pour le
monde j'aime jo je vais tenir mes pions
si tu prends de 60 un pion arrivé en des
6èmes je vais prendre avec ça
j'ai toujours peur contre lui parce que
je me disais je suis sa belle blanche
je sens le problème après des cinq je
sens le problème après des 5
je suis un idiot fini je suis tellement
con [ __ ] c'est horrible d'être aussi
[ __ ] prime sur faut prendre les saints
qui ajuste dames c'est sympa mais je
savais qu'il allait me prendre cette
merde qui fut obligé de faire flamber 3
mais c'est chiant d'être aussi débile
[ __ ] on a laissé complètement perdant
mais à chaque fois de toute façon je
fais de la merde contre lui je sais pas
pourquoi je n'arrive pas à jouer une
bonne partie est qu'elle est bien
préparée contre mes trucs aussi
à
mais j'ai fait de la grosse merde une
nouvelle fois je sais pas pourquoi je
n'arrive pas à jouer contre j'aime jouer
et heureusement sur 3 g dames g6 qui me
fait rêver
planque avec mes pièces
il va prendre b2
je surprends il veut faire dame prend il
fout des quatre matches
à
qui est ce qu'il en fait trop peut-être
qu'il en fait trop
quelle épreuve en quatre sorties de
nulle part je revis il a voulu trop en
faire la vie j'aime jo je comprends
qu'il a à quoi un complexe de
supériorité pour par rapport à moi ce
qui est tout à fait normal et
compréhensible vu qu'ils me défonce
systématiquement mais quand même
boum on est là qu on reprend les pions
allez les mecs
allez on est des durs à l'ailé à l'ailé
brut replace nos pièces la tour qui
revit on revit tous on va prendre un f 7
et on est là à léon le brutalise boom va
surprise prise comme ça il n'a rien n'à
pas de tours qui rendent sur la deuxième
place est interdite ok il veut faire
tour des deux quand même
il veut nous brutalise et quand même
j'aime pas trop ça parce qu'il va mettre
son grand âge silva se planquer que je
vais prendre un set et je m l'adamant
b71 ça je défends g2 le clou ça et j'ai
envie de lui envoyer le pion ça j'étais
sûr qu'on allait rentrer dans cette
position je m la tour en e1 pour essayer
de faire tour 7-6 prend b2 et je crois
qu'il ya pas de mal mais je suis très
malheureux de jouer cette position en
fait ça ok mais il ne menace rien
il ya trop de temps sur la fin du jeu je
déteste que chanteur
non non non il ya cette tour qui va être
en prise non il ya dame province est est
tombé un match mais j'étais sûr que
j'allais me faire avoir fonctionné c'est
trop désagréable à défendre à il est
fort ce james dio à pression était trop
chiante a défendu aurait dû faire h3
j'aurais dû jouer autrement j'ai pas
faut que je me calme il faut que
j'oublie joue contre lui force est sûr
qu'il va magouiller me magouilles alors
sa dernière partie du stream du coup on
va essayer d'égaliser quand tu aimes jo
d'un artiste
manquaient jouer avec h si c'est pas
très grave de laisser faire à chaque
fois cacher le fou non mais ok ça va ah
oui c'est vrai ils jouent cette variante
avec son idée de ouais ok il veut juste
il va encaisser ça en fait
quand je prends ça
quelle je prends ici donc il faut
prendre this et même pas une menace ou
c'est l'audace c'est moi réfléchir une
seconde
j'ai pas envie de lui infliger 6 pour
rien même si je fais cavaliers 17 tu es
fou prosys shekels prend 1,5
il va bouger sont fous
et quand même beaucoup de possibilités
je vais la jouer safe
vous pouvez faire f4 peut-être h5
intermédiaire marque ce rêve 4 suis
peut-être h5 il faut f5 cad mettons
quand je vais grand roque et sa fin je
pensais bien joué de sa part
j'hésite à faire h5 moi même j'avais pas
envie de faire d'un tempo mais je veux
faire cavale b6 au prochain d'un autre
âge pas trop compris en fait
j'ai aucune idée la chicha et d5 arias
d'abord un set
à
c'est sûr je sais pas comment ça se fait
mais il y dans mes pensées et j'ai pas
tour à 5 g rien et je vais contre
encaissé un pion même si évidemment
c'est pas un rêve mais je suis tout est
changé
mais je verrai ce pur h5 au final
il va tenter foulée cas j'en suis sûr
pour venir me faire food et 6 je le sens
donc et d'amd cadre du coup là je vais
venir anna il va me faire couper 4 voilà
ça c'était sûr
et du coup c'est chiant à jouer ce truc
là
ce convoi hyper faible
mais final de feu avec la police et un
fou de vouloir opposer ses qualités du
roi est primordiale et le fou [ __ ]
évincé mort auquel heureusement qu'il ne
voit pas ça respire pas le bonheur quand
même
apparemment on ne tient plus ou moins
mais bon
je conçois qu'on puisse tenir très
longtemps en fait plus un problème de
pendule t'es dur ils ont tenu sans
problème de pendule c'est du coup je
mets un scan de rick perry leurs pions
il va pas faire annuler toute façon lui
c'est sûr
je me défends comme un lion quand même
faire faire tomber
donc elle va nous faire tomber mais
m'ont quand même content parce que dans
l'esprit on a défendu
on va le faire tomber
y'a bien on l'a battue avec le lag
ouais c'est une victoire hyper sign on
est content comptant quelque part c'est
mérité quelque part c'est mérité rond
finir sur une victoire est ok ok pas
mérité évidemment mais on a réussi à
défendre le le dmfu coût d'un fou de
couleurs opposées qui était assez
difficile puisque hockey que leur oppose
et favorise la tacc et on s'est bien
sorti non merci alors suivi les mecs
n'hésitez pas à écrire des petites
questions le tchad sur n'avait encore
après la fermeture du stream et je vous
dis à jeudi prochain ciao